now
as i remember it uh
i first met you in 1876
you were at that time i'd just been made
a full professor in the high school
and uh
i also remember i think that you
gave some lectures at the frank
institute
and did a considerable amount of
electrical invention and
general work in that line while i was at
a tuple at the high school that i know
you did this right i think people will
be interested in that
the description of what you've done yes
i i began my career
of electrical development while still
teaching in the high school as professor
of chemistry
and i gave on the request of the
franklin institute
seven lectures on electricity five
lectures on electricity i should say in
1877
and i heard those two
some
now after that the year following
in 1878
in conjunction with my colleague
professor houston who was associated
with me at that time and for some time
after
in the development of electrical work
we made some tests at the president of
stoop involving dynamos of different
types that we could get at that time
and immediately after that
i designed and built
a dynamo for a single arc light
and
that formed the basis of the uh later
development of the thompson houston arc
light
system these events that you have
described briefly
happened as i remember in new britain
connecticut
we left new britain connecticut sometime
in 1893 heavyweight 1883 1883 now uh
you kindly tell us just what
uh happened
between 83
and 892 when the uh
generally the company was formed by the
consolidation of the thompson house and
then the edison group of government
yes i'm very glad to it is it's a long
story and a great deal of detail but
i'll have to cut it short
and uh i can only say this that the
developments went on at an increased
pace under the encouragement of the new
management and in live in live
and that uh during that period we
developed new types of art labs the m k
thompson and captain rice lamp
which became a standard
then we took up the incandescent
lighting
we took up the automatic current
transformer system which i had outlined
as far back as 1879 franklin institute
and we built the system but we didn't
consider it safe until the development
of the earthing of the secondary which
was invention of mine for securing
safety on the secondary lines of
transformer system i remember that very
well and then we went on from that to
the development of electric welding
which was a separate idea and separate
company was established to carry that on
now called resistance welding electric
resistance welding
we then have an entirely new arm that
was in the art entirely nothing
ahead of it at all
and it has reached an enormous
development today
now
if
the list
would make a very long one to tell of
the number of numerous investments we
took up the uh
electric street railway it took up yes
now the important thing the very
important thing that was taken up
before the consolidation
was the
development of the railway system
to do this effectually mr coffin had
asked me if there was anyone in the ark
that had done the most work as he
thought original original work
in the railway
electric railway
i said yes there was
the man mr charles j
vanderbilt who i've done a lot of work
said to me
mr cochran said to me
can we get him
i said why i think so
he's in chicago and i think his backer's
a little tired
we have sent on first result was an
interview which connected standpoint
with our system and bentley knight also
became it came into the uh
into the company
as a railway engineer
now uh
vanpool also contributed the carbon
brush which is oh yes a very important
method very important very important
method we had had trouble with motors on
cars everybody had trouble with motors
on cars due to the fact that they were
using metallic brushes
vandapal was called into conference with
several of us mr rice among them to find
out whether there was any remedy for the
troubles and vanderbilt in the modest
way said
well i had used some years ago on a
motor a carbon
plate of
carbon brush
and he was told as i remember i think i
said this myself i'll confess that
doesn't seem very reasonable but
we must try everything
and we tried everything but we tried the
carbon brush
and the carbon brush was one of the
greatest successes we ever made in the
in the electric art or the making of the
success
but for generators from
each other all accommodating operators
[Music]
you